hey everybody and welcome to a
tremendous wild ride with Stevo we have
the comedy Legend Joey Diaz this week
and Boyd is he serve up the juiciest
prison story ever and the dirt on
Sopranos I mean it's just comedy and
business and money and juice and you
know what else is tremendous going up to
45 miles at up to 28 miles an hour on a
single charge with the new totally
affordable electric bike from
electricebikes.com dude I'm telling you
this is my favorite new sponsor I've
been riding these e-bikes around and
having a blast my jackass buddy poopies
and I we did e-bike jousting with these
things man I'm telling you never before
have e-bikes been so affordable these
start at just 799 bucks and if you use
the promo code Stevo at
electricebikes.com that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-b-i-k-e-s.com then you
get a free foldable and mountable bike
lock with any bike purchase again you're
going up to 45 miles at up to 28 miles
per hour this thing is awesome and
affordable I mean dude get over there to
electric
e-bikes.com
and join the affordable electric bike
Revolution now let's get into it
um can we turn up the sky Paul can you
make my volume louder I can barely hear
my man
how about now all right I think it's on
our end
okay good man so so you're doing good
things
you're doing good things I'm at home
smoking dope doing podcasts that's it
all right well I I like that
um that's what that sounds like a good a
good thing
you know I moved to Jersey about 20
months ago and
I didn't really want to come here and go
right off the Jump so I just wanted to
I'm like Jim Morrison I want to take a
look around and see where the wind blows
all right I got on stage last week with
Tom Segura for the first time in a year
nice uh
I'll be going out there a little bit
more so dude I love that we've got to
keep all that in but I like to give
people an intro
ladies and gentlemen Joey Diaz yeah dude
and you met Scott Randolph tremendous
Paul Briskey what's up Joey I'm off
camera pleasure pleasure to meet you
pleasure to meet you Paul trust me he is
gorgeous
show us
is that your first time doing stand up
in 20 months he said yeah
wow did you get nervous before you went
up on stage after 20 months
listen to what happened I went to I saw
I went to see a kids
my neighbor's kid plays uh flag football
so I went up there
so we were going out to eat afterwards I
popped a thousand Edibles amazing
[__] edibles
and you know all of a sudden Tom Segura
calls me he's like come on over the NJ
back I didn't want to say to him I just
bought a bunch of apps he's like I'll
send the car for you
so I said [__] it let me go check him
out I hadn't seen him in a year
so I went over to MJ pack and as I
walked in I was gonna go watch the show
and he's like do you mind bringing me up
and it was the weirdest thing because my
legs just walked towards the stage Stevo
my mind was like what the [__] is going
on
and next thing you know I'm in front of
[__] 8 000 people I was gonna say
I've never heard of MJ pack but I'm
guessing it's an arena
yeah it's a little small like a theater
in uh Newark okay I mean 8 000 seat
theater dude I mean he at least gotta
call that an Amphitheater yeah like that
Amphitheater whatever the [__] guys
I'm so jealous and MJ packed yeah I mean
he had packed
um I mean it's not the way these guys
have have taken off with sigura and and
Chrysler I really really against sagura
and Chrysler because you expect that
from Bill Burr and Rogan
you know but these guys are doing Arenas
man it's crazy and you know there's so
many Comics working they stepped up
after the pandemic
instead of going backwards I thought
people would come out and go back to
clubs and work themselves back [__] no
they want back into the fire you know
right and I would love to be able to do
that like I would love to charge 30
bucks and just go out there and dick
around but I can't
I gotta have material to [__] lay
into them I love to go up there and
improvise but that's a 50 50 show
right so when you get the babysitter and
dinner and I'm gonna go up there and
dick around
so I got a plan I'm gonna [__] getting
uh
do some spots and then this summer I'm
gonna jump on birth tour
and then I'm gonna that's he's doing
like a little stadium tour a little
stadium tour oh I heard about that one
yeah yeah like like no this is like uh
you know make minor league stadiums
so it's like minor league stadiums and
like Bristol Tennessee you know right
right right yeah I heard about that and
it's got like there's like there's gonna
be like a whole lineup it's gonna feel
more like a comedy store show than right
yeah how many people have a little
Stadium
I don't know I'm not sure and who else
was on that show you said it's Stacks
Steve who else is on it oh
Nikki Glazer Sam Morel Bert
some other people dropping in to do some
guest spots so it'll be great and it'll
be great to get my you know that's a
great way to get your feet back in all
the pressure is not on me you know what
I'm saying yeah but did 15 scratch my
nuts and go back to my hotel room yeah
I'm more scared of those shows because
and
when I go up in one of those
environments like that's not my crowd
you know and uh I mean I'll do okay but
but I like it when you know when I'm on
my tour and and my my people are out
there and like ah you know it's a
different feeling man
it's crazy I watched George for it too
and you're doing phenomenal you stepped
up too I mean all those shows are sold
out you're adding some shows so I think
people got sick and tired of sitting at
home yeah and they'll [__] it we're
going to everything
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy man and
uh and they like buying merch too
like a [__] yeah yeah
so so now you got into comedies like
pretty late yeah
31 31 okay
it's not late
it was late for me because I just got
out from prison
hip likes
I got out like February of 90.
and it took me June of 91 to get on
stage
nice well I figured sorry okay I figure
you guys have a lot of comment with the
whole cocaine scene in like the 90s and
2000s your guys has passed never crossed
I don't think so here we go you ready
for this I would be an open Padre oh
[__] I I lived in that building behind
it with Ralphie May and Josh Wolf and
you know it was a party so I would pull
him all night
and then I would walk the 7-Eleven on
Curson
to get like a [__] Snapple with
vitamin C in it just to keep me alive
for an hour and I see Stevo going into
7-Eleven and Kirsten buying a case of
beer for here's the kicker he would buy
two cartons of cigarettes so I would
look at you I would never come up to
your disrespected and I would go this
motherfucker's going into war
because when people get not one cart the
cigarette
I don't want to take daylight for a few
days
Steve's night was just starting quarters
and I've been there I've been there
where you just go in there for two days
yeah you know thank God I didn't smoke
that that's how I quit smoking I bought
an eight ball and I went upstairs with
our cigarettes I just locked myself in I
knew I'd get too paranoid to walk to
7-Eleven
so I just sit there all night and smoke
my finger and the next day I'm like I
don't need to smoke again I survived an
eight ball with no cigarettes I love
that man when was that
uh
probably like
September 2007. okay
and then two months later I actually
quit about it
so I'm going on 15 years this November
dude that's epic man I just turned 14
years sober yeah we were both in the
same class
same class same graduating class you
know
I'm happy I got it out I'm happy that it
dog I was 44 when I quit and
I was not uh optimistic it wasn't
looking good for Uncle Joe
and then I watched Ray the ray movie
okay and I was like that dude snorted
heroin
so he was 65 you know that just be the
end I'd be working on the subway with a
ponytail you know with a big bald spot
telling kids about Led Zeppelin In 69.
that's not how I started this so
that 15 and you know what everything
happens to me after I quit my wife got
knocked up I got married
comedy opened up the podcast came
so I'm happy and now I wouldn't even
think about it with fentanyl and [__]
forget it
yeah I'm glad I got out before fentanyl
too man
um for you Joey I know you still like
smoke weed and stuff dude were you ever
like just completely completely sober
and like trying to make that happen I'll
tell you whether you're completely sober
or not it is a darn good idea to drink
more water and less beer and why not
drink a water that looks like a beer
that's right liquid death baby that's
what I drink because it comes in an
infinitely recyclable can which looks
exactly like a beer and it's from the
Alps dude best water in the world
telling you because it's infinitely
recyclable cans their whole deal is to
bring death to Plastic Man you know that
75 of aluminum that's ever been produced
is still in circulation meanwhile
Plastics just cluttering up the ocean
killing wildlife and get how generous
this company is you go to
liquiddeath.com
Stevo and you're gonna get free shipping
on all your orders of merch and water
and you know how heavy water is dude no
more lugging it around from the store
you just have it show up at your
doorstep for free shipping for free I
mean come on get on over to liquid death
dot com slash Devo order yourself some
water get absolute free shipping support
the podcast and support this company
that's saving the world it's a good deal
and I love it so hell yeah
liquiddeath.com Stevo now let's see how
sober Joey Diaz is
when I got to Jersey you know I was
eating 2 000 milligrams a day in L.A the
stars of death I was smoking an eighth
of weed you know you go to The Comedy
Store somebody's giving you a blunt
you go to church somebody's giving you a
blunt you know so when I moved back here
I was really I was withdrawing on Xanax
which is basically the worst feeling you
could ever go to
once the Xanax starts rebounding your
anxiety
you think you're gonna die
so when I was going through that I was
trying to eliminate anxiety so I quit
for about nine months
quit espresso quick coffee pretty much
yeah
and I wanted to get my tolerance a
little down
so I started smoking about six months
ago
and I'm Tip Top [__] Magoo I'm happy
Tyler's still down you know
and you said you survived covid and uh
yeah I got covered in December and did
you start taking Edibles or just keep
smoking
no I smoked like I think that I got a
Christmas Eve
I think Christmas day I was puffing
already my temperature was down then
Rogan sent a bag of vitamins over here
on Monday
after that I was tipped up with goop
um did in December was it already the
Omicron
it was the old macron yeah that didn't
flying sad no that [__] that you got a
headache yeah had a lot of sweats
you know a little bit of breathing for
about a week you walk up the stairs too
quick and you're like what the [__] just
happened but nah it was good I'm happy I
got the [__] version
I got the antibodies and uh let's see
what happens next let's see if they're
gonna scare white people this summer the
same obamacron is coming
we're once you've gotten
I'm a crime be it you know ah
so like Nancy Pelosi got it yeah
you know [__] uh
Governor Murphy from Jersey had it last
week
so it's making like a half a fact come
back but it ain't gonna do big
people are over it yeah over here
they're like [__] you in your [__]
mask
and you know I move I'm living my life
if I get it it's three days
what's the big [__] deal I mean if
there's no war in Ukraine and Russia
there'd probably still be coveted but
since that's taken over the headlines
like nobody hears about it anymore
but that's fizzing the [__] out that's
got to settle get off the [__] pot
they gotta [__] up get off the pot over
there yeah either we start bombing let's
start by let's get this party started
you get beat up by [__] Ukraine right
now they got you in the 16th [__]
round and you're still playing games
we're still sanctioning either drop the
[__] where's the Chinese let's go
[__] let's get this about these
thoughts
they've been like playing [__]
handball enough let's go yeah they're
like the top three military in the world
oh where's the [__] Korean let's go
[__] you guys been threatening for
a long time where are you now your
Crane's [__] up Russia by mistakes
and they're still [__] tick-tocking
you know get the [__] out of here
yeah dude so so uh the the cigar show is
in New York
Jersey you're in Jersey but you were
just in Austin too
I did Rogan about four weeks ago yeah
and I'll tell you our uh our jackass
girl Rachel Wolfson was that's my girl
she's so grateful for for you uh giving
her love on that she's uh I've known her
for a long time she's a hard worker
and when I saw that she was blowing up
on Twitter I gotta be honest I was
[__] ecstatic
because you know between the slap
between all the stupidity that goes on
in that [__] armpit of a business
with the [__] you still get one ray
of light every once in a while and for
me it was Rachel Wilson
you putting it on jackass on her you
know blowing up she's if anybody
deserves it it's Rachel man that's so
great and I gotta say thank you for
supporting me all all these years always
you're my [__] nut I love you I did
okay I'll go into you crazy that's how
much I love that if you called me and
said we're going to Ukraine let's go I'm
going with it
I got a ton of respect for you man you
got a a great thing and you made me
laugh a long time on that [__] thing
I love jackass you know I used to laugh
my first I'm like what the [__] are
these crazy white people doing and then
my stepfather watched it he was all
Cuban so he would call me and go these
[__] white kids are crazy I don't
know what they're doing he couldn't
understand it so he's the one that
turned me out the jackass
man that it's just it's just epic dude
so and so when you uh flew out to Texas
was that uh like
your first airplane in a while
uh no I went somewhere Where'd I think I
went to Nashville to visit my in-laws
and then you know I tell you I saw all
the fights on planes and I couldn't
figure it out until I got on a plane
they drive you crazy with that face
Master dead
it's on [__] speed dial knock it off
I'm trying to watch [__] you know
jackass on Amazon or whatever the [__]
it is right and keep reminding you
reminding you reminding you no wonder
you want to snap like a twig
so I don't really want to go anywhere
until the 18th
is that
that's what it ends Oh No More Mess on
planes
April 18th the Mandate ends wow wow
that's cool
uh you know after the pandemic I I got
some some dates on the books I I got on
one [__] airplane with the mask and
then going through the airport and I was
like dude I called my agent I was I said
yo man [__] I'm on my hands and knees
begging you for a [__] tour bus run
and that did we rented a tour bus there
was like crazy expensive it's like we're
making the money on the tour it's all
going to the bus and I said you know
what I'm gonna buy a piece of [__] RV
and pretend it's a tour bus
and that's what you did yeah yeah he's
three weeks on two weeks off he's been
on the road for like the last three
months
so you're gonna drive everywhere you've
been driving it yeah dude I I don't even
[__] with airplanes dude like uh I'm
John Madden
that's a great idea yeah because he's
been avoiding planes like most people
avoided covet I was supposed to go to La
yesterday playing castle three times
wow
man so we we heard that uh because I
think we would we we went to New York we
were trying to get you on the podcast
when we went to New York and I think
that they told us uh Joey's not doing
podcasts in person only on Zoom is that
right
I don't know what it was there was a
time when
you know I was I just moved back here
and didn't want to move a lot I was you
know people were pulling on I just got
off a [__] plane and people offered
me [__]
and I go guys let me take some time more
do you know what I'm saying let me just
see what the hell is going on my
daughter I had to put her in a new
school
you know I live around the corner from
Jimmy Florentine the rock guy the comic
guy that Todd Ozzy's Boneyard so
I just wanted I was going on yeah I
didn't really want to start going into
the city like I went into the city
to shoot The Sopranos when we had had
scenes
I didn't like what I saw
like it just wasn't good you know how
maybe I have it backwards and what they
said was Joey Diaz won't do podcasts on
Zoom he'll only do them in person I
can't there probably was a face of that
too
who the [__] knows if you're in it from
an agent who the [__] you know man
unless you call these guys
you know when an agent hits me up for a
podcast I don't know what's going on
right like why is the agent hit me up
you know this ain't their world so it's
kind of confusing
so me too sometimes sometimes I don't
want them to go into that world
I don't want you in that world because
I'm not pretty soon they want a
commission for that [__] [__] you I know
how that works over that so you know
they got beat up by not taking
commissions on podcasts and nobody would
give it to them and now they restructure
an agencies to dip into our gidus
and it's like I ain't giving you [__] of
my podcast you're gonna have to suck my
dick two times you know what I'm saying
good fight
you maggots were pushing the road in the
middle of the pandemic and I'm making
good money with a podcast and you guys
want to come into my podcast go [__]
yourself I remember years ago telling
them like I'm like they would call me up
and go hey The Improv wants you to come
in on Wednesday and I go I'm not coming
in on Wednesday I got a podcast on
Wednesday night
and they would go oh they're going to
read through the date redo the [__]
date I don't give a [__] tickets were
sold out they ain't we doing [__] they
just want to kind of like beat you up a
little bit if you go down there the
night before [__] you I got [__] to do I
mean it's incredible the power of the
podcast it's a game changer for the game
changer for everybody yeah it's
unbelievable I always knew if I could
tell my story I would do okay
if you were just going to judge me on
going to see me at the store it wasn't
going to work out for me
but if I got to tell my story and you
got to see my heart and [__] now we're
gonna [__] rock with you [__]
you know so that's how I always felt for
me like I hate when people go send me a
tape [__] you
I'm at the store at 10 30. you're on
you're in Beverly Hills that's right I
got the Habit when I was a comic I would
never send a fake and if I did it was
black and it would be fantastic for them
to call you back and tell you how they
enjoyed your day
yeah yeah that's that's how you got the
longest yard from a blank tape from a
black no the longest shot I had to send
them audition thing they didn't want to
see me they wanted to see stars I don't
blame them but I was like wait a second
Adam Sandler's doing the movie last I
checked he's a [__] comedian this is
going to be a comedy how the [__] do you
not want to see me so I just made an
audition tape and send it to him
and I got the roll that's how I got it
you know
dead
so uh maybe when you just said if I can
tell my story and and in my head I just
thought ooh I like tell us tell us a fun
prison story
all right you're about to hear a prison
story that's so intense chances are your
heart rate is gonna go skyrocketing and
you can know exactly what's going on
with your heart if you wear a whoop band
I'm telling you this is the most
sophisticated Fitness tracking device
known to man and the brand new entirely
waterproof whoop 4.0 can be yours
absolutely free if you sign up for a
whoop 4.0 membership this is going to
give you insights to your sleep your
recovery how many calories you're
burning what activities you're doing
you're going to know more about your
health overall than any other way I'm
telling you and you get 15 off your
membership if you use the promo code
Stevo at checkout this is all going down
at whoop.com that's w h o o p.com you go
to whoop.com you use the promo code
Steve where you get 15 off at checkout
and you're joining the fitness
Revolution at the highest level so do it
now and let's go to prison
I was I was telling these guys at the
gym the other day
we were talking that was about two
months from getting out
from going to a halfway house and
usually when you go to a halfway house
or you get now people start messing it
because there's such miserable
[__] they don't want you to go
nowhere either
and since the time I got in there it was
like you know there was the white
supremacist dudes then there was the
bikers
then there was like the heroin junkies
then there was the Mexicans
a couple of Italians and that's it you
know a couple guys had HIV you know
that's how you categorize it you know so
there was a guy on the biker crew that
would always break my balls
but he would always break my balls when
he was at the bikers
he would never break my balls when he
was alone
now I had the support from the Aryan God
the Aryan guy was out of Philadelphia
he just disregarded that I was Cuban and
me and him would do like a line of meth
every Monday and go play basketball and
[__] he was all up he hated Jews he
hated everybody he just like he just
didn't make believe my last name was
Diaz but this guy was in there for
murdering the pagan so he was pretty
[__] tough you know so I hung out
with him I hung out with this mobster we
ran like a book operation like pools you
know three and seven you know that [__]
so I'm just about to get out of a few
weeks from getting out
but probably like six weeks we're
getting out and I and this dude muscles
up to me in the kitchen now between me
and you I could have taken him and two
of his buddies out but like I don't pay
attention to those guys like if you if
you know you could crush a dude why am I
even gonna [__] pay attention to you
but he kept trying to be cute
he worked in the kitchen with me so we
all had to live in the same dorm
so one day I'm looking at him he's
cutting like onions or something and I'm
the I'm gonna charge you the kitchen
like he worked for me
and I'm looking at this [__] butt and
I'm like what can I do to this
[__] before I leave so it was
the same day we were unloading American
cheese like that government cheese in a
box
and I took a tremendous [__] I took like
a 19 inch [__] covered with [__]
granola and you know I [__] in a box I
put it in that
American cheese box and I put a little
American flag that we had in the kitchen
for like uh BLTs
and I sealed the box and I put it in
this bottom drawer hidden under clothes
after a week that room smelled like 10
dead [__] Puerto Ricans okay even the
brothers that would walk out would go
what the [__] is that smell they were
like we ain't they couldn't even walk
through that entrance that's how bad the
kids room smelled how much that ate
[__] something that night like pork
burritos or something that [__] room
was on fire and finally one day he found
it
he was covering his face with a T-shirt
and he had a glove on he's carrying the
box now when I [__] it was like 19
inches it was down to like four inches
they had like some worms in there and
[__] now and he's yelling I know who did
it I know who did it I know did it
so he didn't wrap me out but now I knew
he was going to strike on me and I'm
like he ain't striking on me I'm gonna
shut that [__] down
so like two days later we eat breakfast
and I see that he's walking to the
laundry room
by himself he ain't got the muscle man
with him
so I just followed him in there the
reason I don't have long hair and I
would never have long hairs because
somebody could [__] rap with this
fight
this guy had long hair so he was putting
his laundry and I walked up behind him
and I tapped him on the shoulder we
turned around I basically grabbed his
locks with this wrist and then I grabbed
the other [__] thing I pulled them
aside and there was like a a a board
with activities and [__] you know go to
church on Sundays you know I banged his
head off that board like 15 [__]
times
and he just slid and fell he passed the
[__] out the next day I saw him he
didn't say nothing the next guy saw him
he didn't say nothing the fact he never
said nothing to nobody
he knew it was me he turned around I saw
his eyes [__] he didn't think I was
gonna jump him but I got him in that
room
and that's it I love it I don't know I
don't prison
it's fun it's not what they say
now you can't smoke you know when I was
there it was 30 years ago
and you can still spoke you know they
were piss testing but we could do acid
so we were just doing Ash a couple
nights a week you know you've been
smoking that
I was lifting weights in there I went to
jail in Golden Colorado
by where they make cause
three blocks away is the coolest place
so man thank you for telling us that
dude like we love prison stories why
that's crazy [__] it's just fun man like
prison stories are fun
um and you said that you were just at
the gym that guy you're looking good man
yeah I dropped like 30 pounds since I
moved back here you know I go to the gym
a lot uh uh Jiu Jitsu I joined Gracie
up and they have a lunchtime Class A
bunch of old guys [__] tremendous
I did I went there today it was three
days a week I try to go I went Sunday
Wednesday and today
and that's it the weekend I got softball
games with my daughter you know she's
playing softball
we live in central New Jersey it's very
uh cool here big for the kids you know
if you try to pick a [__] he'll die you
better you better double up on the
masturbation gloves because they ain't
nothing here for you but a lot of kids a
lot of parents you know I think uh 70 of
households have two kids under 18 in
this spot wow did you always want to
move here this guy moved here did you
always see a time like this coming where
you're like all right eventually we'll
just get like a nice place kind of slow
down a little calmer environment or did
the pandemic kind of make this happen
sort of when the pandemic came we I was
the pan we got shut down on the 13th
the soprano movie got shut down on the
16th of March
I was coming back that week to finish up
the move
and I had like three days I was shooting
and then I was doing two nights in Nyack
and in between that I was going to look
for a house in Bergen County
once a pandemic uh
happened
we didn't know what we were going to do
and then they said no school
and me and my wife said that's not
happening gotta go to [__] school
so everything got rushed up but I'm
happy it did
but in the long run yes once I had my
daughter
I knew I couldn't stand out of life for
a long time it's not a good place for
kids
for sure so this day was coming and the
pandemic just kind of made it come a
little sooner yeah just escalate I just
pushed the Fate up you know hey were you
worried about coming going back to
Jersey because you know I I listened to
your podcast you had a lot of stories
and running into old people or have
raising your daughter there and I'm
dying to know if you ever ran into your
driver's ed teacher that used to do coke
with he died he died he died George
McGrath died about seven months ago but
after I started telling stories about
him on podcast he wouldn't even [__]
talk to me on Facebook so
but he died yet during the pandemic
camel breath because he used to smoke
camel no filters and his mustache was
red and the pictures were [__] red
that's when you know you're not [__]
around
that's great but yeah were you I mean
were you worried about going back to
Jersey like a lot of old reminiscent
stuff are you excited you know what man
I thought about him anybody come looking
for me now
obviously got no [__] life you know
that [__]
happened 30 years ago and it and it
reminded me because I had to remember
like this ain't the same but it was this
is different you know
people have moved on people don't give a
[__] you know
so it worked out perfectly
some kid hit me up when I first got here
you robbed an ounce of coke you owe me
1500 that was in 1982. [__] call a
judge will you stop bothering me
an ounce of coke for 1500 bucks that
sounds like a pretty 1982 deal yeah 86
87 or something Aspen he came up to
visit me and he didn't want to bring it
back on the plane so he left the bed
that's not my problem you left it here
now you want money for what are you an
Indian giver
probably like two weeks later where's
the money there ain't no money you left
it here so what's up with The Sopranos
movie
it got released they had a bag of dog
[__] and we're on to the next mine [__]
oh [__] I love The Sopranos movie for
the record yeah
it's just listen it
it did what it did but you know our good
friend said it to me he saw it early on
and he goes it's an okay movie
but the whole time you're sitting there
waiting for Tony Soprano to jump out
and he goes that's the problem with the
movie so I didn't know how I was gonna
hit
HBO released it for free so we got
[__] at the box office so
listen you know what you win something
you lose some and you move the [__] up
yeah
that makes sense to me that's all you
can do you know you don't after you act
in the movie you don't control that
[__] right but I I wouldn't
consider that a loss I mean like uh
everyone Raves your performance that's
awesome and honestly I love The Sopranos
and I loved that movie I thought it like
filled in so many gaps in the story that
we sort of didn't know and showed you I
I loved it and being on HBO during the
pandemic like [__] you must got a lot
more eyeballs than you would about a
theater right is that the idea oh it did
great on HBO they had like I don't know
how many millions of views but that
makes my pocket like so [__] you and
your eyeballs I want my money
you know [__] porn stuff I need to
collect concept because that was funny
you know what you're with sag they
always [__] with you so that was my
insurance money when I saw they were
giving the movie away for free I'm like
oh you're [__] with my finger in the
ass you know
I need that insurance so was there any
ever ever talk about where the movie was
supposed to come out in theaters
yeah it was supposed to come out in
theaters and it did it came out October
1st but they released the [__] HBO
the same time so you're gonna do the the
Scarlett Johansson move
yeah you know if I had titties like
Scrabble I would do it but I'm just an
old-fashioned you got
you got acting [__] in the works right
now
you know like uh I did an episode of we
crashed on Apple TV and a lot of people
are saying you know when I shot it I'm
like who the [__] has Apple
you know but Jesus Christ people have
reached out to me some guys told me in
jiu jitsu
it's a show with uh Jared Leto and okay
yeah that's on Apple TV I play detective
big [__] deal man it's crazy the uh
they put
um our new Jackass movie on Paramount
plus streaming and we're in the same
boat that you just described you know
Paramount plus streaming great you take
our movie and you get everybody wants to
see our movie so they'd sign up and they
pay subscription to Paramount plus but
we don't see any of that so what you're
asking us to promote your streamer when
like you get the subscription money and
like we're just bringing you subscribers
and we don't get a penny for that
um and uh it it was interesting but in a
conversation that we had about this they
told us that Paramount plus has 20
million subscribers and that feels like
that just popped up out of nowhere like
how the [__] does yeah because
Yellowstone Yellowstone put them on the
map in a big way and dude they ran it
down I mean what is it what is Netflix
have like 800 million or some just crazy
[__] yeah
it's insane man all this streamer and
[__]
it's a different world you know so
you gotta live with it a lot of people
aren't paying what they used to right
I think about the young
actors that are coming up and you know
what they have to deal with now rules no
social media you know when I shot a show
and for a different streamer and they
sent me a list of rules
and I almost [__] my pants I'm like I
didn't get into acting to [__] have
rules you know right I mean personal
rules but
I got on the set there was a great shoot
and I had a good time but
uh it's tough out there to make a pimp
practice you know they want you to join
sag then they want to give you these
hundred dollar a day movies then Alex
Baldwin shoot you in the [__] head
moving I get shot in the [__] head by
that [__] what were some of the rules
that they gave you yeah what's the no
social media rule you know like listen
if you let's say I'm on jackass at the
end of my rap I go to hug you and
somebody takes a picture I can't pull up
on social media oh gotcha I mean dude
the movie gets released no video of me
and Johnny no video of me and Stevo no
video of me and Rachel I can't complain
about that that makes sense yeah then
they they don't want you talking about
it on uh you know I mean you think about
us comedians you come to our show you're
you're not [__] invited to pull out
your cell phone and Steal My Show that I
worked so hard on it's the same deal
the same deal so I could see that you
know but not really I wanna I wanna let
people know that I got on [__]
jackass right that's true it's just a
picture of me and you going like this
before
you get the cart before the horse if
you're promoting the jackass thing
before it's time to do that then that's
wasted opportunities so if they tell you
to wait until it's coming out to [__]
time everything to come out together
they just said no ah well that's
[__] yeah there was a lot of little
things that so you know when I got that
lay a fifth [__]
desktop was 15 grand a guest star now is
like 3 900.
you know Harris and how to bid you're on
a stream you know when you work for
Netflix there's no residuals
when you work for happy streamers or
residuals it's a one [__] shot deal
well guess what you know I did an
episode of uh
Law and Order SUV I don't want to tell
you how much I've made on that
so on that residual I've made more every
time they repeat it they play at eight
o'clock that's prime time for me so
those residuals were big you know [__]
cut out the residuals towards Insurance
during the pandemic they got some beef
now you know [__] Sharon Stone don't
have insurance Sharon Stone showed her
monkey on that [__] screen 30 years
ago that little bald [__] clam she's
got it's hard to believe she don't have
insurance you follow them
you want to see my nutsack but Sharon
Stone don't have insurance Jesus Christ
what the [__] well you got to earn a
certain amount to you know to stay
current in your sag membership and 30
years ago like if I if I'm sad if I'm
the insurance company I'm not trying to
still be paying out for some [__] that
happened 30 years ago it's like
residuals always counted towards your
insurance okay
during the pandemic sag said [__] you
and they got sued now they're getting
sued by Asner he [__] died
sag tried to get the dismissed and they
said [__] you we're moving along with
this lawsuit
wow so they took our residuals away
during the pandemic did you shoot
anything during the pandemic I mean
podcasts and jackass yeah jackass did
come back early yeah talking about the
first nine months of the pandemic nobody
shot dick
so that's when they canceled
the things
about 20 [__] five years
how can a union guy that's been in there
for 25 years in a union and 59 years old
doesn't have a [__] insurance you
want to answer me that I will not argue
with you there yeah so no no that that's
sad that [__] unit is whacked and I
ain't doing no a lot of movies because I
don't want Alec Baldwin shooting me [__]
him in his [__] [__] family I
don't give a [__] yeah dude
[Applause]
um so what like with with social media
yeah I mean you got all the Instagram
you got a YouTube channel and [__] I got
everything
no Tick Tock though I'm too old to
[__] be tick-tocking you know what
I'm saying I don't know man I I I I uh I
got on that [__] man oh I hear I hear
it's doing great for people
people making money and stuff I got like
nine fake accounts people [__] put me
up there and say [__] so
what are you gonna do yeah man at least
it's promoting you a little bit you know
like yeah Scott will just post clips of
this podcast on his Tick Tock and they
do amazing yeah like it's good for us I
put up eyeballs Mayan Bialik the girl
the new Jeopardy girl things got [__]
like 9 million views on Tick Tock and I
put up [__] Jody Sweden she's got like
nine million I mean it's and I got 50
000 followers it just explodes it's
bizarre yeah the Jody Sweden clip is
where she says I was born in prison I'm
like you were born in prison that's
awesome yeah that's not that's a nine
million clip
so it sounds to me like uh you know
especially with the pandemic and
everything the podcast is the biggest
nut for you
well I took a hit not going on the roof
right you follow him right of course
touring with me first then then podcasts
podcast has been good you know I've been
doing it for 10 years so I got YouTube
for you I got a ton of [__] you know so
it works out for me that
I'm not trying to impress the Joneses
either like I don't have a BMW me either
I don't go to Hawaii I don't need to you
know
I'm 60. I'm just happy I'm walking
around and slinging dick and smoking
weed and trying to be a dad I ain't got
time to be [__] you know doing all
that [__] so it worked out for a guy
like me I got some great sponsors yeah
so it'll be worked out so do you have a
podcast sponsor which you come out and
say is your absolute favorite
because it's bad for business to do that
but I do it anyway no I have I have a
cup I love liquid IV yeah I like [__]
DraftKings with all my heart you know
I love better help you know I went I
took therapy during the pandemic and
signed up to better help and then I
reached out to them
and they let me do some ads for them so
I got them
I love
shaving my balls I got
dick pills Bluetooth
we got we got the same kind of uh I
don't
yeah we've got the same sponsors man I
love them
I love on it I love their products
uh-huh I'll talk to see if I can get you
because you should be on you should
definitely have on it yeah I would love
that
um now you didn't mention my favorite
one which is tushy dude the [__]
toilet seat bidet do you have that thing
yeah I I put them on the map I took them
in when no agency would work with them
and then they went to an agency
they kicked ass over the pandemic but
she's trying to talk to me now to get
back but you went to an agency you got
to come in with a bigger envelope now
[__]
you know what I'm saying so she's trying
to come back with the same number but
Papa we gotta up the [__] Annie right
now I'm not on the road no more so right
if you want to post [__] bidets you
gotta sniff my nut sack let's get this
party started yeah you got that that
toilet seat one
yeah yeah
it feels the weight of my [__] ass
cheeks on the seat and it goes beep and
that's how I know that it's [__] the
seat is warming up to the temperature
that I like and then I'm [__] just
[__] with my feet on my beautiful
Squatty Potty which I love and I'm
[__] when I get done I push the
button and the water's heated up to the
[__] temperature that I want and it
just starts
just pressure cleaning my butthole do
you only use a tushy dude I can't stand
[__] without my tushy when am I when
I'm on the road like uh that's why I'm
addicted to these [__] uh
dude butthole wipes the wet wipes you
know I can't [__] just take a [__]
and use toilet paper anymore I feel like
an animal if I do that
it's like that scene in Wayne's World
where they're like just doing all the
sponsors and [__] yeah
my house growing up oh did you yeah
I remember the first time I was taking
this [__] and I looked at it and I just
turned it on it just hit me in the
[__] face I was like eight
and then I thought it was disgusting and
I started using it when I was like 10 it
was [__] tremendous no paper your
[__] don't stink that bad you get all
the [__] peanuts out of there yeah
yeah close them out hey for you doing um
therapy through better help was that
your first time doing therapy
yeah
nice yeah I I I'm I feel like I need
therapy I've never done it but uh it
seems like good for everybody dude I
[__] needed therapy
because I get so bent out of shape with
[__] doing stand up and the [__]
[__] [__] up the show yelling
stupid [__] where they're [__]
screaming I'm telling a joke and they're
screaming at the same time so nobody
hears my [__] joke and then like dude
I'm like you just [__] up my joke you
[__] up my show [__] you [__] I hope
someone throws you across the [__]
Street and then kicks you when you land
you [__] [__] and I get soap bent
out of shape and then with the people
videotaping the show I get so I had to
get into therapy for that and I use
better help for that
I'm happy you do yeah you know I never
thought of therapy and then when I moved
back here
like I said things were moving too fast
a little bit
my anxiety backfired
I wasn't well so a friend of mine
recommended them and I uh signed up for
them
and the rest is history on Tip Top Magoo
I'm getting arlons everything's
beautiful you know what better help did
to the [__] world of therapy is what
Uber did to taxi drivers
you know now it's like dude therapists
used to be like a pretty [__] you
know like the like the taxi drivers had
to work for years and pay all the money
to get the Medallion you know to be like
a certified therapist is a big deal now
it's like [__] Uber [__] oh [__]
did I go on better help
they have so many therapy sites now they
have their precise
that [__] give you medication
they got their work of it they're doing
great job but you can't believe you as a
therapy site that gives you medication
you know maybe you could [__] either
Bluetooth get a harness and [__] the
therapist I don't know what happened
yeah therapy with a happy ending I like
blue chair man I always used to thought
I was thought about like the idea of a
dick pill like Yo dude I don't have
[__] problem getting a boner I don't
have [__] erectile dysfunction [__]
that I'll have nothing to do with it but
then I switched my my I switched my
perspective to think you know what like
what if I just do it for fun like what
if it would be fun to have a more
[__]
outrageous boner and uh and it is
you know I like it because it's 30
milligrams when you take the hundreds
you wake up the next day like you got
raped you [__] the heart hurts you're
ridiculous
your balls hurt with dirty it's quick
you give her a stabbing everybody's
happy you gotta bang one out on your own
to keep that [__] from going
through your jeans and that's it
but I heard there's a pill out of
Thailand that you take on a Friday and
you sling dick till Monday morning but
give it to me next week at a health food
store he sees like [__] 80. and he
has to get three day hard-ons with these
pills out of time it's like steak juice
and monkey eyes or something it's a
perfect combination for a [__] dick
explosion
they're in Thailand Thailand is a creepy
place man
I went I went there and I I didn't want
to you know what I was like okay if
we're shooting let me know when it's
call time I'll show up to the set but
other than that I'm not leaving my hotel
room
I don't blame you I won't even go to
that I'm scared I don't have a passport
they took it away when they found the
machine gun
[Laughter]
if I did I still wouldn't go to there's
a lot of countries that are just creepy
they scare me
and uh I'm okay staying here in the
United States I'll take my chances in
Idaho you know what I'm saying dude I
love it what uh how many comedy specials
you got
just two one on Netflix and one with
that [__] company
oh what that [__] uh that company
don't make don't mention that
yeah he had no idea what's coming his
way that [__] the guy with the two
last
hyphen yeah
he has no [__] idea
does your life really change once you
get a comedy special on Netflix I mean
is it like uh is it pretty wild
you know man
I had a half hour special
and they gave me notes the night of the
shoot
which is always a [__] real pleasure
so uh yeah it helped listen everything
you do
comes back to help you in levels and
degrees
you know like when I did the longest
shot I get mad but it matters now now
people will go holy [__] they'll go now
and watch Analyze That of Spider-Man 2.
while I was doing it didn't matter you
know everything matters at the end
because you don't know what's going to
make people twist you might do a movie
with [__] uh you know Matt Damon and
you're like oh [__] get ready to suck my
dick and all of a sudden nobody watches
it
and like you do a stupid commercial for
Big Daddy and you're a [__] star yeah
that's what and you do you got to give
it 100 percent
because you don't know when that eyeball
is gonna [__] land on you
you know it's not what it used to be
you could do 10 movies now nobody knows
where the [__] you are
because this has changed the game what
we're doing right here
so I think this is just as important now
dude this is the biggest thing I mean
it's crazy yeah I was trying to explain
podcasting to my dad my dad was saying
like how can something that uh you're
just sitting around compete with
something that you work so hard on to
Paul and make it like what I do with my
comedy is multimedia and I go out and I
shoot the [__] the most insane [__]
and I put it all together in one show
where you get the craziest [__]
footage you ever saw with the the stand
up I worked on so hard for so long and
my dad's like why would anybody want to
see you just sitting around I said
because Dad like
people feel like they're sitting there
with you you know they really develop
they get to know who you are they really
like uh they develop a [__]
relationship with you you know they they
know you as a person they feel close to
you and then when you come to town they
really feel like they need to be there
with you
and it's so true a different experience
you know 10 years ago if you did two
episodes of a show on a CBS you sold
tickets uh
our friend that was on
Billy Gardell
he's on two CBS shows nobody will come
see him anymore
this is what people are waiting on
you'll sell more tickets from this [__]
look at all these young influences
I see like three tours going on
with three young influencers taking
Headliners on the road
so what does that tell you people don't
even give a [__] how about seven and a
half minutes of material yeah like in in
just for laughs Festival like before us
some YouTubers went off and they're
selling out the entire [__] crowd of
a huge theater I'm like who are these
guys they're like dude they're just
YouTubers you know yeah and dude well
it's a different world guys how about
the [__]
how about the [__] big venues that
are sold out on a [__] Tuesday
afternoon with everyone paying to buy
tickets to go watch [__] play video
games on the stage
it's crazy we're living
it's a different [__] world and like
I tell people listen
you want to make money get on that
[__] computer
there's a thousand scams on that [__]
thing
thousands
you know I just hooked up with amp amp
is a uh app that you can do a radio show
on you can promote your own radio show
now
ten years ago you couldn't do that
you got to talk to people to sign up for
amp and they can listen to you for free
it doesn't cost a dollar
and they got Biggie Smalls they got
Black Sabbath they got everything except
Let's uh Leonard Skinner if I didn't see
ma'am so what is that like SiriusXM or
some [__]
no it's an app you download and you do
you create your own radio station no
boss
so it's like YouTube except Audio Only
yeah you do a radio show like you make a
playlist of songs
yeah and you get on there all right this
is Stevo I went to a [__] strip club
last night and some Channel and then you
just play a [__] song I don't know
man that's crazy is it live or is it
like pre-recorded live
look at the [__] questions download
the [__] thing
I forgot
with that so you just got on stage doing
stand up you said you're getting ready
to do some more stand up but have you
have you booked any dates yet
not really no not really I got no
material right okay
yeah let me take my time I got the
summer I got I got two months before I
gotta do anything you know
I'm taking my time right
and uh do it I'm in no [__] Rush man
dude
I I uh
I'm I'm ready like I'm I'm running my
tour right now this this show The Bucket
List tour I mean dude I went [__]
over the top man I had [__] I got a
medical professional in Disguise to
administer stolen general anesthesia
drugs in my arm while I'm riding a
[__] bicycle through a field you know
like [__] like that dude illegal as [__]
I got another one I got [__] butt ass
naked
with another man strapped to my back and
a [__] airplane I'm butt naked with a
dude on my back I'm jacking off to a
[__] portable DVD player and I I blow
a [__] load simultaneously as I fall
out of the [__] airplane I'm coming
everywhere falling through the sky it's
[__] skyjacking this is the [__] that
people see when they come see me on tour
I I tell the story about like all these
[__] ideas and and how crazy it was
to make them happen like how my fiance
felt about it and then after each bit I
screen the footage and uh you know
you're seeing [__] that you're never
it's gonna [__] you up for your life you
know the [__] that I show you on my show
and uh dude I'm running it I'm gonna run
it and run it because dude I how many of
these shows do I got to do the next one
I I'm my next tour is going to be called
gone too far I'm just going I'm crossing
the line I'm going to get the I'm gonna
go find out how big a [__] tits I can
get surgically [__] boob jobs
I'm getting [__] tits I said this to
Nick Swardson on one of the very first
episodes of The Wild Ride podcast
I said I'm getting tits and he's like
you know like people think I'm [__]
around I'm not [__] around dude I'm
gonna have a big ass [__] dick
tattooed on my forehead like a [__]
legit dick tattooed on my forehead I'm
gonna have [__] huge tits and that's
just where I'm getting started dude
laughs
yeah and I can't wait that's gonna be my
material dude like I gotta find out
being a being a [__] a a male a man
who identifies as a man and a
heterosexual man you should think that
that I I can post myself on Instagram
with my shirt off
but does that change when I got tits I'm
still a man who identifies as a man and
I'm heterosexual whether they can have a
[__] problem because I got tits I
gotta find out
there's only one way to find out but
only one way dude
you know there's a lot of things I need
to find out
well I got your back go for it dude I
love it man you know you're one of the
very few people who aren't who are okay
with my ideas man you know I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna spill them all out on here
but dude I can't wait and here's where
I'm banging my [__] head against the
wall is that I can't get my specials on
Netflix
for two reasons number one like they're
they're very uh like snobby about [__]
you know they're like oh we don't really
[__] with the jackass guy who's [__]
got into stand up you know like and the
[__] that I'm doing with multimedia is
like too [__] up for them to show
maybe you know but the situation I'm in
I think is identical to the [__] Jeff
Dunham nobody wanted to see a
ventriloquist stand-up comedian they're
like we're not into ventriloquism you
know and in my case like nobody we don't
want to see the [__] [__] stunt
guy shoving [__] up his ass calling it
stand-up comedy you know but Jeff Dunham
broke through and [__] Joey dude I'm
not giving up dude I'm not giving up and
I don't even care but I'm so glad that
I've had this this resistance against me
and what I'm doing because it's just
[__] motivates me and it's gonna
taste so sweet when I finally [__]
breaks through like Jeff Dunham did
and if I gotta get tits to make that
happen
I'd stop by lighting my balls on fire
first I already done it admit the
[__] tits you know what I'm saying
yeah I got together with my buddy bam
Margaret lit my balls on fire and he put
him out by kicking him
that's defend this [__] right there yeah
I don't [__] around Joey
I know that that's why I love you to
death dude I love you too man hey what
up was like what what kind of [__] can
we send people to
for you I'm on Joey's joint it comes out
on Mondays and Wednesdays I got a
patreon I got I'm on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram Matt flavor
mad flavor
and I'm coming to a town near you in the
future you know what I'm saying yeah the
balls I'm flying and [__] strap on
the pair of titties got something we're
coming damn you and I have followed each
other on Twitter for years man I always
felt so grateful that you did and and
man I've been sleeping on your other
Pages dude I'm gonna jump on it right
now dude is that what you want Instagram
mad flavor
yeah Matt flavor yeah dude
I was sleeping on that [__] dude I'm
gonna [__] jump on your your
Instagram your Facebook
and uh to tell us again about the
podcast
yeah it comes out on Mondays and
Wednesdays on uh YouTube Apple Spotify
you know every usual [__] subject
yeah everywhere you get your podcasts
what did man I [__] it's an honor
Joey and and yeah it's an honor that you
reached out I love you to that so dude
nah you always gotta hold me with Uncle
Joe dad I love it man we forgot how to
[__] set up the computer to do a
podcast on Zoom we didn't know how to
[__] do we were racing scrambling to
get this ready because we're like what
the [__] dude like what do we even do
with the computer and and then on top of
that it's 90 [__] degrees outside and
it's the first the first [__] time we
had to figure out how to get the the
goddamn air conditioner unit set up in
the man we're like Dude Where's the like
we didn't have the connector I'm sitting
here trying to duct tape the air
conditioner hose to the [__] unit
over here we got Joey Diaz waiting I'm
[__] ripping duct tape off that thing
like it's crazy man there's nobody else
I'm not gonna see nobody else very few
[__] people that we're gonna set up a
zoom to to talk to on on the Wild Ride
podcast man but it's an honor to do it
with you I appreciate it brother I'll be
in touch with you guys sooner than later
hell yeah dude I'm gonna follow you on
IG
broad on the
on the okay I love you guys thank you
very much
have a great week it's a tremendous
episode man
my cap peace peace well if you weren't a
fan of Joey Diaz before I think it's
probably pretty safe to say that you are
a fan of him now
I [__] love that guy I really do man
and his Support over the years has
always just really meant a lot to me you
know what I'm gonna say your support for
sticking around to the end of this
podcast it really means a lot to me just
sending some love out to my street team
and uh shoot dudes maybe you know maybe
you don't but my [__] book just went
on it's on pre-order my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions and
between you and me man I'm dying for
this [__] book to be number one on
the New York Times bestseller list like
it's that good I genuinely [__]
believe that I should be the number one
New York Times best-selling author and
uh help me get there by ordering it just
order yourself the one [__] copy and
if you get it like uh pre-order then
that's the way to get get a signed
hardcover so yeah man this book's epic
dude and uh pre-order it now we're
putting the link in the [__]
description yeah love you guys thank you